wie können die strengen corona maßnahmen
gelockert werden und vor allem wann
diese frage beschäftigungs natürlich
alle und vor allem deswegen auch die
politik die hat die leopoldina also die
nationale akademie der wissenschaften
darum radke begriff gefragt und den hat
sie bekommen am wochenende mit einem so
genannten ad hoc bericht den haben 26
wissenschaftler gemeinsam ausgabe sind
aus ganz verschiedenen disziplinen und
darin schlagen sie jetzt eine
schrittweise lockerung der massnahmen
vor welche davon tatsächlich umgesetzt
werden und wie dass wir die
bundeskanzlerin morgen mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder
besprechen und dann bekanntgeben
was davon umgesetzt werden soll das
wollen wir aber heute schon miteinander
beraten und mal gucken wo die
stolperfallen und tatsächlich die
fragezeichen sitzen mit doktor christoph
specht der arzt und medizin
korrespondent und die fragen an ihn sehr
gerne in die kommentare stecken da
werden wir dann versuchen so viele wie
möglich zu beantworten aber bevor wir
loslegen
damit verschaffen wir uns einen
überblick was die politik gerade an
maßnahmen und lockerungen diskutiert und
wo vielleicht da die stolperfallen sind
heute morgen in der uniklinik gießen der
gesundheitsminister und der hessische
ministerpräsident wollen sich vor ort
ein bild machen und lernen immer noch
dazu
in der debatte um den lock down ist
gesundheitsminister sparen einer der
ersten der sich für eine vorsichtige
lockerung der maßnahmen ausspricht wenn
in bestimmte bereiche des einzelhandels
zeigen können dass das geht so wie die
supermärkte es uns ja auch zeigen jeden
tag das ist geht dann kann man das
sicherlich auch auf andere bereiche im
einzelhandel übertragen eine vorsichtige
lockerung das empfehlen auch die
wissenschaftler der leopoldina in halle
eine lockerung nicht nur für kleinere
geschäfte sondern auch für schuhe
grundschulen und die sekundarstufe eins
also bis zur zehnten klasse dürften
schrittweise wieder öffnen so der rat er
ist in der fachwelt und politik
umstritten
ich halte die empfehlungen der
leopoldina für eine unter vielen bin ich
der auffassung dass das in allen
bereichen überzeugt ich bin schon gar
nicht der auffassung dass es überzeugt
bereich der grundschule
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass wir
diesen weg gehen werden keine
alleingänge ein einheitliches vorgehen
aller 16 länder fordert der
nordrhein-westfälische ministerpräsident
mit wenigen ausnahmen nrw zum beispiel
will nach den osterferien die schulen
schrittweise wieder öffnen um zumindest
abschluss prüfungen durchführen zu
können wir haben andere abitur termine
als andere länder
wir haben andere ferientermine als
andere länder
also hier brauchen wir eine flexibilität
in grundsätzlicher übereinstimmung und
die opposition sie fordert erst einmal
die voraussetzungen für eine lockerung
zu schaffen genügend schutzkleidung
genügend tests und im zweifelsfall eben
auch genügend personal noch ist keine
klare linie erkennbar
nur der berliner regierende
bürgermeister hat schon mal angekündigt
das vor ende april in der hauptstadt
nicht mit lockerungen zu rechnen sei und
lockerungen gibt es ja bekanntlich nur
wenn die regeln eingehalten werden mit
abstand halten hat es bei politikern und
ärzten heute in gießen nicht so
funktioniert ja große diskussion also
viele stolperfallen viele fragezeichen
und über die möchten wir jetzt heute
abend treten mit doktor christoph specht
arzt und medizin korrespondent also
medizinjournalist beschäftigt sich seit
wochen natürlich mit der krise hallo
herr specht hallo wir haben das ganze
mal in
die blöcke aufgeteilt weil dadurch
einige fragezeichen sind datenerhebungen
ist die eine frage die andere ist die
öffnung der kindergarten und der schulen
dann diese mund nasenschutz pflicht im
öffentlichen personenverkehr oder masken
wie es ja umgänglich umgangssprachlich
heißt die dauer der maßnahmen und dann
auch unsere corona müsing müdigkeit ich
fang mal vorne bei den daten an die
leopoldina vorschreiben ich zitiere mal
ist es wichtig die erhebung
desinfektions und immunität status der
bevölkerung substanziell zu verbessern
insbesondere durch repräsentative und
regionale erhebung desinfektions und
immunität status also das soll quasi
durchs ganze volk hindurch geguckt
werden wer hat die krankheit schon
gehabt und wer ist wie infiziert kann
das überhaupt klappen
ja das kann schon klappen wenn man das
aber kurz auf deutsch mal übersetzt
heißt das wir wollen ja gerade mal was
empfehlen aber haben eigentlich noch
nicht die entsprechenden daten die wir
dringend bräuchten um diese daten sind
eben wie viele sind wirklich infiziert
wie viele hatten die erkrankung schon
haben also antikörper dagegen gebildet
und diese daten liegen tatsächlich
aktuell noch überhaupt nicht vor jetzt
gerade beginnen die ersten tests dazu
das sind etwa drei studien die sie als
beispiel herausfinden wollen zb münchen
läuft eine wie es denn in der
bevölkerung wirklich aussieht denn in
heinsberg hat man ja gesehen in einem
dieser hot spots das natürlich schon
mehr leute corona dieses neue virus
sowie 19 hat sind auch wenn sie
vielleicht gar keine symptome hatten
aber diese zahl ist natürlich
entscheidend um zu wissen wie sieht's
aus mit der humanität wenn es eben um
die sogenannte und immer wieder zitiert
der herdenimmunität geht aber erst
öffentlich ein bisschen leichtfertig
tatsächlich jetzt schon über lockerungen
von maßnahmen nachzudenken wenn man noch
gar keine daten erhält und so wirklich
hat also kann man muss auch mit dem
missverständnis aufräumen
die leopoldina hätte da quasi eine
studie vorgelegt das ist ein ein
thesenpapier das haben wir auch nie
behauptet dass es das wäre er keine
eigene forschung dazu betrieben alles
was hier gesagt und gemacht wird das ist
neuland sowas hat es noch nicht gegeben
weder gibt es eine wissenschaftliche
gute datenlage
für das einführen dieses lockt da uns
dieser schließung von allen möglichen
geschäften und des öffentlichen lebens
fast generell noch gibt es
wissenschaftliche daten wie man sowas
eigentlich am besten wieder zurück führt
sie hatten ja schon kurz angesprochen
die sache mit den schulen keiner weiß
wie man das eigentlich richtig macht und
wo eigentlich die ansteckungsgefahr am
größten ist beziehungsweise was welche
auswirkungen hat all das ist noch
wirklich neuland und bekannt man muss
auf der anderen seite auch ohne dass
diese daten schon vorliegen natürlich
irgend mit irgendetwas anfang und ich
glaube genau da ist die problematik
versteckt jetzt gibt es ja den vorschlag
auch von anderen wissenschaftlern dass
man apps benutzen soll das lka hat ja
schon draußen die kann man sich
herunterladen
ich hab dir mal ausprobiert man muss
erstens so eine smart watch haben oder
ein fitness armband dann muss man das
die ganze zeit tragen also nonstop man
muss ein schlaf checker benutzen und man
soll sie ja die ganze zeit mit sich
führen und zum beispiel bei mir während
der temperatur gar nicht gemessen da
habe ich mich gefragt was bringt denn
dann so eine app wenn sie im endeffekt
ja nicht so hohe ansprüche stellt dass
ich die gar nicht wirklich erfüllen kann
mehr es gibt natürlich verschiedene apps
es gibt ja auch eine die mehr darauf
abzielt die kontakte später
nachverfolgen zu können man sich ja
vorstellen momentan läuft das so jemand
wird also möglicherweise positiv
getestet das gesundheitsamt im idealfall
erfährt davon oder sagt dann eben selbst
dem entsprechenden bescheid und müsste
dann telefonisch händisch tatsächlich
die einzelnen kontakte herausfinden
sagen wo waren sie denn in den
vergangenen 14 tagen wann haben ihre
symptombeginn angefangen mit wem hat sie
den kontakt themen haben sie länger
vielleicht standen sie näher gegenüber
all das muss also händisch gemacht
werden und da kann natürlich eine app
die untereinander die handys sozusagen
vernetzt und sagen kann mit welchem
handy letztendlich klare aufträge
klammer zu man längere zeit beisammen
gestanden hat da können diese apps
natürlich tatsächlich helfen die anderen
apps die tatsächlich daten erheben
wollen im sinne von nader fieber oder
nicht bzw wie bewegt er sich diese
natürlich mehr auf die tatsächliche
symptomen findung gedacht ich halte
selber mehr von der anderen art der apps
also die die kontakte zurückverfolgen
aber auch die müssen ja alle benutzen
sonst macht das erkennen sind nicht
unbedingt alle aber sehr viele das ist
so ein bisschen ähnlich wie die zahl mit
der herdenimmunität da ist es ja auch so
dass nicht alle immun sein müssen aber
eine große anzahl und das hängt dann
auch immer wieder davon zusammen wie
ansteckend das virus ist also dieses
sogenannte basis reproduktions zahl
spielt da eine rolle bei coop 19 bzw saß
cause 2 geht man eben von diesen immer
wieder zitierten 60 70 prozent der
bevölkerung aus und so viele müssten
auch ungefähr diese app benutzen damit
sie wirklich was bringt sogar zum großen
thema schule öffnung und auch im
dementsprechend kindergarten eröffnen da
wird hier schon sehr viel diskutiert ob
das heißt eine gute idee ist oder nicht
ich guck mal hier auf youtube gerade
sultan in die kader schreibt die schulen
öffnen ist gefährlich andere wollen
wissen werden jetzt die schulen öffnen
oder nichts das kind noch nicht sagen
das wird erst die nächsten tage erst
beschlossenen andere schreiben schulen
schließen oder bis zu den sommerferien
schließen alles andere ist wunschdenken
also da ist hier das was ich so gerade
jetzt nicht sehr repräsentativ lese
relativ eindeutig der tenor die schulen
erstmal zuzulassen
die leopoldina hat aber jetzt empfohlen
die jüngeren erstmal kommen zu lassen
was denkt denn da dahinter ja wenn man
auch hier glaubt das war so mein erster
impuls der würden wissenschaftliche
daten dahinter stehen also irgendwie
eine überlegung oder daten dass man
sagen kann bei den jüngeren ist
vielleicht diese infektionsgefahr nicht
so groß oder andersrum besonders groß
damit werden immunität bekommen nein da
steckt da gar nicht dahinter sondern hat
sich auch überlegt wie es sozial
verträglich ist was kann man tun welche
kinder müssen als erstes wieder in die
schule zum beispiel hat man gemeint dass
diejenigen die einen übergang gerade in
einer stufe sind übergang zu einer
anderen schule dass die am ehesten
wieder den präsenzunterricht haben
sollten weil es sonst im digitalen
bereich da etwas schwierig wird was man
nachvollziehen kann
aber daher kommen diese etwas auf den
ersten blick kaum nachvollziehbaren
empfehlungen sie sind nicht
begründet in biologischen
epidemiologischen daten sondern eher
dass man sich überlegt hat ja welche
kinder müssten am ehesten in die schule
damit es ihnen selbst etwas bringt
natürlich sind kinder
diejenigen die sich schnell anstecken
man hat dann auch gesagt ja wir lassen
die älteren eher in die schule gehen bei
denen kann man die hygieneregeln
erklären dann gibt es natürlich sofort
kritik daran die sehe ich auch dass die
kinder und jugendlichen die sich dann
länger nicht gesehen haben werden
wahrscheinlich alles andere tun als
zumindest über einen tag hinaus dann die
hygieneregeln einhalten also ganz klar
ist wenn man die schulen wieder aufmacht
in welcher abteilung nun auch immer dann
werden die infektionszahlen wieder
steigen das rk ii ist er genau der
anderen meinung man sollte zuerst die
älteren in die schule schicken und dann
die jüngeren weil die sich nicht an die
abstandsregeln halten jetzt gibt es hier
wirklich große diskussionen sind wir
hier 2 kommentare einmal auf facebook
von mel frau die sagt die zukunft
unserer kinder steht auf dem spiel wenn
der lok tor noch lange dauert es muss
vorsichtig und langsam zurück zur
normalität gegangen werden also ich lese
die sorge einer mutter das quasi ihre
kinder nicht die schulbildung bekommen
die sie natürlich brauchen
beziehungsweise irgendwann ein
komplettes jahr hinterher hinken oder
zumindest ein halbjahr darunter arbeit
gleicht der kommentar von mir lieblich
sollten jetzt unsere kinder die
versuchskaninchen spielen
wie kann man denn zwischen diesen beiden
positionen jetzt überhaupt einen
kompromiss finden
das wird ganz ganz schwierig und ich
glaube diese beiden posten zeigen
eigentlich das spannungsfeld und man
sollte glaube ich auch gar nicht so tun
als gäbe es die richtige antwort dabei
wie gesagt das ist vollkommen neu ich
glaube es gibt hier keine richtige
antwort jedenfalls die man jetzt schon
wissen könnte hinterher vielleicht schon
das verrückte was wir erreichen müssen
ist wir brauchen nicht keine ansteckung
keine infektion das würde uns auch nicht
helfen
wir dürfen aber auch nicht zu viel
infektionen haben das geht ja darum dass
die menschen in der bevölkerung eine
gewisse immunität bekommen das wäre
eigentlich gut auf der anderen seite
darf aber die ansteckungszahlen nicht so
hoch sein dass eben circa 14 prozent
sind ja schwerer erkrankt die dann
hospitalisiert also ins krankenhaus
wir gehen müssen dass diese 14 prozent
absolut in der zahl nicht zu hoch sind
und dann das gesundheitssystem
überlasten also es hat noch keiner
gemacht und ich glaube es gibt die
richtige fertige antwort auf diese frage
nicht man wird einen mehr oder weniger
versuch starten und dann sehen wie gut
es läuft oder ob man nach korrigieren
muss jetzt gucken wir uns mal die
kindergärten an auch da ähnliches
problem die kindergärten seit jetzt die
leopoldina oder empfiehlt ist auch ohne
grundlage von daten zumindest habe ich
keine gefunden oder studien die
kindergärten geschlossen zu lassen bis
zu den sommerferien da fragte ich mich
jetzt wie soll denn da in der produktion
oder produktive wirtschaft in gang
kommen wenn alle eltern quasi zu hause
bleiben müssen
jetzt da gibt es auch keine erfahrungen
wahrscheinlich ne nein nein ist genau
das gleiche bei großen unternehmen die
das vielleicht irgendwie schultern
könnten wäre es vielleicht noch machbar
aber wie soll das flächendeckend gehen
das ist der tat ein ganz ganz großes
problem gerade in den berufen also von
den eltern die zum beispiel im
gesundheitssystem tätig sind das war ja
das was auch in italien in spanien sehr
sehr schwierig wurde wo diese eltern
nicht nur ausfielen weil es sich um die
kinder kümmern mussten sondern weil sie
auch noch selbst dann erkrankt waren
also das ist tatsächlich ein völlig
ungelöstes problem
und ich weiß auch nicht auch keine
lösung ich glaube niemand weiß ich ja
ich guck doch mal in die kommentare hier
nachteil die user facebook die richtige
antwort ist gesundheit
da gibt es dann auch schon zum 2 gleich
baum gleich zwei daumen hoch
prima fragt was ist mit den kindern die
eltern haben die vorher erkannt sind
auch das ist ja tatsächlich eine frage
die ist glaube ich von der leopoldina so
gar nicht beantwortet worden was sind
solche audios oder zum beispiel in den
schulen hat man dann gesagt was ja vom
epidemiologischen her sinn macht dass
man sagt man hat kleinere klassen ja das
wünschen wir uns seit jahrzehnten
kleinere klassen
wenn das jetzt mal mit dem hand strich
geht ist das super aber ich fürchte das
wird kaum zu machen sein
denn was heißt dass kleinere klassen das
heißt ich brauche mehr lehrer
ich brauche mehr räume man muss das
ganze neu organisieren
es ist gut gedacht aber ich glaube es
ist nicht umsetzbar
hier ist auch eine frage von sascha
decher kann ich mein kind zu hause
lassen weil ich angst vor einer
ansteckung habe da kommt dann
tatsächlich die frage was liegt höher
die schulpflicht oder die sorge um die
eigene gesundheit
das problem würde auch aufkommen klar
dass dann leute sagen ich schick mein
kind gar nicht in die schule
ich lasse es zu hause dann hat es
natürlich arbeitsrechtliche konsequenzen
wieder wenn die schule angeboten wird
und eben für in vollem betrieb oder
zumindest den betrieb für dieses kind
läuft dann wird man schlecht begründen
können warum die mutter der vater dann
zu hause ist zu betreuung des kindes das
sind noch vollkommen ungelöste probleme
richtig wirbel gerade auf youtube
kommentar gefunden ich das gerade
weggesprungen leider stand quasi schule
öffnen ist wie corona partie
damit gefährden wir uns selber oder wenn
ich corona wegen der schule bekommen wir
wen kann ich dann verklagen ja
wahrscheinlich niemanden würde ich jetzt
mal sagen eine josi ziel anspruch
darunter auch ganz eindeutig meine
kinder sollen kein kanonenfutter sein
ich habe hier fast noch keinen kommentar
gefunden muss ich sagen der in die
richtung geht ja schule öffnen macht
sinn also zumindest wenige wenn wir mal
ja ja ich wollte sagen das risiko liegt
eigentlich aber auch weniger bei den
kindern wir wissen ja dass die kinder
zwar sehr wohl auch infiziert werden sie
sind sehr gutes spredder sie geben also
auch weiter sie haben selbst relativ
wenig bis keine symptome
das wäre noch nicht mal das große
problem wobei natürlich auch einzelne
kinder dabei sein können mit oder
vielleicht auch in einem ausnahmefall
ohne vorerkrankung die heftige erkranken
aber diese kinder würden natürlich dann
wieder als verbreiter gelten und ganz
klar ist sobald man hier den betrieb
wieder anfährt ganz egal wo man ihn an
fängt es erst recht in den schulen dann
würden die infektionszahlen natürlich
nach oben gehen
wenn wir dann noch einen schritt weiter
gehen eine andere empfehlung ist ja das
öffentliche leben möglichst zu lockern
und die leopoldina empfiehlt das tragen
von mund nasenschutz als zusätzliche
maßnahme in bestimmten bereichen wie es
heißt wie dem öffentlichen
personennahverkehr
da soll es eine pflicht geben da gibt es
ja jetzt schon seit einigen wochen wir
haben die diskussion hier immer wieder
auch im livestream und in unseren ganz
normalen programm überall lasten auf
oder runter ja oder nein wo stehen sie
denn in der diskussion so ganz
persönlich also ich habe meine meinung
der tatsächlich nicht geändert man muss
bei der masken diskussion folgendes
bedenken es gibt untersuchungen die
haben mal nicht zu gewohnter sondern bei
anderen erkältungskrankheiten geschaut
ob es etwas bringt wenn die bevölkerung
solche chirurgische das waren damals
einfach diese
einfachen chirurgische masken trägt ob
das was bringt dabei hat man
herausgefunden es hat nichts gebracht
das hat zur empfehlung geführt dass man
sagt nein also bei erkältungs zeiten
macht es keinen sinn wenn die
bevölkerung diese masken auf warum ist
das so weil bei dieser untersuchung hat
man nicht nur mit einberechnet wie diese
masken funktionieren sondern man hat
auch ein berechnet wie die leute sie
tragen und in der tat wenn man nach
draußen geht sieht man dass wie sie sie
tragen dann werden natürlich sehr viele
fehler gemacht dass diese masken nicht
viren dicht sind ist klar das ist aber
noch der kleinere punkt sondern was
häufig passiert ist die leute ziehen
sich die maske an vielleicht auch da zu
diesem zeitpunkt noch mit sauberen
fingern aber dann fummeln sie im laufe
des tages immer wieder an der maske
herum schauen dass der sitz richtig es
drücken sie noch mal anfassen außen an
ob sie das mit handschuhen tun oder ohne
ist völlig unerheblich das ist nicht so
gedacht für diese masken sondern die
setzt man sich einmal auf seinen händen
und dann lässt man sie in ruhe
das heißt tatsächlich sind diese masken
fremd schutzmasken sie können helfen
wenn ich selber infiziert infiziert bin
ob ich es weiß oder nicht und ich dann
feuchtere aussprache habe husten niesen
das dann eben diese tröpfchen in denen
die viren verbreitet sind nicht so gut
nach außen kommt die kommen auch nach
außen aber nicht so gut da für sie diese
masken wirklich gut als selbstschutz
wirken diese masken auch übrigens die
selbst gestrickten baumwolle masken also
die selbst gebastelten relativ wenig
aber und das als letzter satz wenn jetzt
viele eine solche maske tragen würden
dann würden natürlich auch die eine
tragen die möglicherweise infiziert sind
ohne es zu wissen was und könnte so ganz
verbreitung etwas etwas auch eine
suchmaske ja dann könnten die eben dazu
beitragen dass das infektionsrisiko für
andere nicht so hoch ist deswegen halte
ich durchaus für richtig zu überlegen
wenn man was lockern möchte ja zum
beispiel in verkehrsmitteln wäre das
vielleicht eine sinnvolle maßnahme
ich schaue mir gerade mal in die
kommentare da gab es jetzt auch schon
die frage wer bezahlt mir denn die maske
also für mich und meine familie da sind
da lese ich so ein bisschen tatsächlich
auch finanzielle sorgen wenn man jetzt
keine tuch maske nimmt sondern die etwas
professionelleren mund nasenschutz den
auch chirurgen tragen der kostet geld
also da kommt so eine frage auf
andere fragen ja adelbert meint massen
werden während dicht wenn sie richtig
aufgesetzt sind und wenn sie einen
filtermaterial haben das geeignet ist
da widerspricht er ihn ich glaube da
muss man ein bisschen ihr differenzieren
oder das geht erst bei mp2 mp3 los die
sind ja klassifiziert ff p2 p3 das sagt
sagt etwas aus über die partikel anzahl
die diese filter zurückhaltend
die chirurgische masken können keine
leeren zurückhaltend dafür sind wären
viel zu klein und diese fb2 vor allem
die ffb drei masken dass sie diese rund
abschließen denn manchmal mit ventil
masken die können wenn sie gut sitzen
tatsächlich wären auch abhalten hier
kommt auch noch mal ein widerspruch auf
periscope sehe ich gerade von tobi 44
falsch masken schützen auch beim
einatmen
wieso also ich frage mich gerade so ein
bisschen wieso so viele menschen auf
einmal masken fachleute sind und
tatsächlich widersprechen sich aber auch
die fachleute teilweise in ihrer
einschätzung das macht die sache nicht
einfacher
auf den letzten posten zu gehen gegen
also viren kommen dadurch was die maske
im passiven schutz leisten kann also
eine einfache maske auch so ein baumwoll
maske ist dass die tröpfchen die ein
anderer in meine richtung hustet
hoffentlich auf der maske außen hängen
bleiben dann könnten die viren immer
noch dadurch durch das einatmen aber die
tröpfchen würden erstmal draußen bleiben
das heißt man könnte ein das risiko ein
bisschen minimieren jetzt sitzen diese
masken aber natürlich nicht wirklich an
der haut im gesicht wie es sein müsste
und wie gesagt das gewebe an sich lässt
die viren durch kommt nächster punkt
noch hinzu diese masken werden ja alle
weil sie halt knapp sind mehrfach
getragen das heißt viel länger als sie
jemals im medizinischen betrieb gedacht
waren da hat man sowas 23 stunden an und
weckt damit dass diese masken werden
natürlich durch das viele tragen auch
nicht besser und auch nicht dichter also
ich fast mal zusammen eigentlich wären
allemal wäre es gut in allen ausgetragen
würden und sie richtig benutzen würden
sie würde regelmäßig gereinigt
regelmäßig gewechselt man halt trotzdem
sicherheitsabstand ein
und da kann man noch einmal zurück zu
dem foto war zusammen was als heute was
heute auf twitter um gegen die
legen wir kurz auf meinen rechner das
ist nämlich das bild aus der aus diesen
ich glaube uniklinikum war das da sehen
wir herrn sparen da sind wir herr
bouffier da sehen wir auch irgendwo es
kanzleramtschef das ersparen dass der
bouffier da ist mir der kanzleramtschefs
helge braun das ist glaube ich auch noch
alle dicht gedrängt in einem viel zu
kleinen aufzug da frage ich mich wenn
schon die politik das nicht hinkriegt
herr specht wie soll das ist ganz
normaler mensch ich sehe dass ich sehe
das bild zum ersten mal ich fürchterlich
lacht ich finde es fantastisch also das
ist genau das was nicht funktioniert die
maske ist kein ersatz für den sozialen
oder für den abstand zueinander das
funktioniert nicht die maske ist
natürlich in dieser situation dann schon
immerhin besser als gar nichts aber ich
weiß nicht warum die alle in einem
aufzug fahren mussten
tja das ist eine gute frage die jetzt
noch mal eine ganz direkte frage an sie
von andreas maria muss ich eine
baumwolle selbst geschneidert
tatsächlich dann jeden tag waschen
ja und wir konnten dann sollen sie auch
noch bügeln schön ist ja das sollte man
schon machen ja coronaviren das weiß man
so ab 60 grad vertragen die nicht gut
zur sicherheit sollte man die dann also
bei 60 grad oder höher weil die meisten
waschmaschinen ja nicht unbedingt 60
wirklich bieten wenn da 60 grad dran
steht also lieber ein bisschen wärmer
noch waschen was man auch machen kann
übrigens mit papiermasken man kann sie
in den backofen legen
damit mache ich die nicht steril aber
dass corona virus geht dabei kaputt gott
sei dank ist das eben nicht so
wahnsinnig stabil dieses und wenn ich
das sicherheitshalber 20 minuten 30
minuten im backofen bei 60 70 grad läge
dann kann ich diese maske ist nicht ganz
optimal aber dann kann ich diese maske
tatsächlich noch mal verwenden hier geht
es zu den masten tatsächlich noch mal
fragen direkt auch in verbindung mit
schule weil es ja die frage gibt ob
nicht auch mal als abi also
abiturprüfungen doch noch geschrieben
werden in den nächsten wochen und zwei
kommentatoren wollen wissen ich kann im
abi nicht sechs stunden sondern
schutzmaske auf haben sagt erika was
soll ich tun und sabine gold fragt wenn
die abiturienten schutzkleidung oder
mund masken tragen wie soll man sich
denn da konzentriert
ja sehe ich ein weil jeder kann sich da
vielleicht selbst sich vorstellen wie
das ist in der prüfung oder sich daran
erinnern dass das alles eine
sondersituation da kommt es auf den
richtigen bleistift drauf an wenn man
sich da darauf eingesungen hat also
insofern kann ich das verstehen dass man
irritiert ist durch so eine maske
vielleicht gebe es auch eine möglichkeit
nicht persönlich würde das so sehen wenn
man die tische die er sowieso sehr weit
auseinander stehen müssen
damit keiner vom anderen abschreibt wenn
man da die abstände wirklich groß wählt
und die leute anschließend dann die
masken aufziehen würden also während des
schreibens an sich nicht dann würde ich
aus medizinischer sicht sagen würde da
nichts dagegen sprechen so wir bleiben
beim thema masken das scheint die leute
wirklich zu interessieren
nochmal 2 kommentare der kommentar
dritte gerade gesagt hat er glaubt es
nicht dass es nicht doch hilft fragt ob
nicht vielleicht aktivkohlefilter die
viren zurückhalten könnten
nein nicht wirklich
denn würde man schon gemacht haben es
ist tatsächlich eine frage des gewebes
man muss bedenken diese diese viren sind
ja so klein dass man sie mit normalen
lichtmikroskop gar nicht sehen kann
deswegen als er so lange dauert bis man
sie überhaupt entdeckt hatte als die
influenza die große spanische grippe
1918 da wusste man nicht dass das werden
bakterien und de die viren sind ebenso
für ziemlich klein dass sie wirklich da
überall hindurch können wie gesagt sie
sind am normalerweise am ersol gebunden
an diesem wassertröpfchen und die werden
durch so eine maske auch durch so eine
papiermaske wenn sie halbwegs frisch ist
durchaus abgehalten aber es ist eben
kein wirklicher hundertprozentiger
schutz vor allen dingen sie hatten so
richtig schön zusammengefasst wenn man
eben fehler beim tragen macht der
vernunft mehr anfassen an dem asta ist
eine frage von gabriele welches papier
ist das beste das vollkommen dicht ist
sie hat ihre masken aus staubsauger
tüten genäht auch interessant da kenne
ich ehrlich gesagt keine studie
schmeißen nicht wie es damit
funktioniert kann man vielleicht auch
machen ich glaube dass man aber so
kompliziert gar nicht denken muss auch
dieser baum wollmasken wo man das an
baumwollstoff ja nimmt wenn es nicht
gerade gehäkelt der schal ist er
wirklich nicht sonderlich dicht ist dann
hat das eine gewisse wirkung um eben die
feuchte aussprache zu reduzieren aber
wie gesagt um es noch einmal klar zu
machen
wirklich in erster linie von mir als
maskenträger zu meiner umwelt das ist
übrigens der grund warum auch die
asiaten diese masken tragen
es ist weniger der eigenschutz sondern
mehr der fremdschutz zur letzte frage zu
den masken und dann machen wir das thema
dicht nennt sie möchte wissen laut
apotheke sondern fep2b ffp zwei masten
aus lüften lassen stimmt das ja das ist
richtig
wenn man also normalerweise schmeißt man
die weg da wird gar nichts gelüftet
weggeschmissen
aber wir haben eine sondersituation wenn
man überhaupt schon so eine effect 2
oder mp3 maske trägt und die eben nicht
für das medizinische personal vorgesehen
ist oder vorbehalten ist dann kann es
sinn machen die tatsächlich hinzulegen
nicht in irgendein geschlossenen kasten
oder sowas und dann offen hinlegen wenn
jetzt die sonne scheint in den nächsten
tagen dann ist es auch immer ganz gut
die sonne drauf scheinen zu lassen wirkt
auch etwas wie ruhe zieht zumindest
behindert es die viren also tatsächlich
offen liegen lassen oder eben in den
backofen das ist ganz praktisch habe
weise kritik gab es auch nochmal
kommentare auf teleskop ob man die auch
in die mikrowelle legen kann und da
wurde gleich beantwortete effekt sei
nicht bekannt einer uv desinfektion oder
in der mikrowelle
das vg uvc qvc strahlung das ist ja was
also kein bereich benutzen hat aber das
haben wir ja nicht in der mikrowelle
mikrowelle würde nur wärme machen und
das wird natürlich mehr wenn das weiß
jeder wenn ein essen warm macht wenn da
flüssigkeit drin ist das bei der maske
ja eben nicht der fall wäre mir zu
unsicher
gut also dass masken thema beschäftigt
viele menschen wir haben das versucht so
gut wie möglich zu besprechen
aber natürlich die große frage ist wann
sind wir die maßnahmen los bzw
wie lange dauert das ganze noch viele
menschen sind jetzt schon nach den
wenigen wochen corona müde es fängt auch
so eine art gewöhnung an
dabei heißt es ja immer wir sind erst am
anfang der pandemie und nina niebergall
hat mal ein paar zahlen dazu und stimmen
gesammelt
wie geht es den deutschen in der krise
wie viel verständnis haben sie für die
maßnahmen
das ermittelt die sogenannte cosmo
studie woche für woche psychologin
cornelia betsch ist daran beteiligt
sehen in den letzten drei wochen dass
die risikowahrnehmung ein wenig abnimmt
wir sehen auch dass die akzeptanz der
maßnahmen ganz bisschen abnimmt der
aussage die maßnahmen sind stark
übertrieben stimmten vor zwei wochen
noch 15,5 prozent zu vergangene woche
sagten dass schon 21,1 prozent
es ist ja auch so dass wir in einer lang
anhaltenden krisensituation print und da
ist es genauso wie mit muskeln sorgen
und ängste können nicht für immer ganz
feste anhalten sondern auch bei muskel
ist es so wenn ich den sehr lange
angespannt haben muss ich ihn irgendwann
entspannen und genauso was konnte hier
auch stattfinden eine art gewöhnung die
wir hier beobachten und so lange die
nicht damit einhergeht dass die leute
aufhören die maßnahmen zu befolgen ist
das auch gar nicht schlimm
und das ist der studie zufolge noch
nicht der fall
ein meter fünfzig abstand halten daran
halten sich nach eigener aussage 96% und
auch kontakte auf den eigenen haushalt
oder eine andere person beschränken
das machen immer noch 91 prozent der
befragten
tja also großes thema wann sind wir
diese maßnahmen wieder los darüber
sprechen wir heute mit doktor christoph
specht arzt und medizin korrespondent
ich lese ihnen gleich mal ein kommentar
vor die nicht gerade rein bekommen habe
auf facebook leider müssen wir öffnen
schreibt anderen kehl kein land der welt
überlebt einen längeren stillstand
entweder beschränkung bis impfstoff
kommt oder öffnen leider vergessen die
leute auf dass die wirtschaft nicht von
luft und liebe lebt nun geringer teil
kann es sich leisten 618 wochen zu hause
zu bleiben
das muss kündigen oder hat das club im
home office arbeiten zu können so dass
es die eine sache die anderen machen
sich sorgen um ihre gesundheit gibt es
irgendwie erfahrungen viel eine
gesellschaft so etwas durchhalten kann
da müssen wir wahrscheinlich eher ein
wirtschaftswissenschaftler fragen oder
ein soziologen mir ist nichts in dieser
richtung bekannt aus dem medizinstudium
biologischen kann ich sagen weiß man das
aber auch nicht auch da kann man nicht
sagen wie lange das eigentlich sein
müsste es gibt natürlich zahlen modelle
die immer wieder
rechnet werden vorgelegt werden und die
verheißen er nichts gutes die würden
nämlich sagen wir müssen das noch sehr
sehr lange durchführen da ist einmal die
rede von der herdenimmunität wir hatten
schon darüber gesprochen
die dann erreicht werden müsste und die
kriege ich ja nur hin entweder durch ein
impfstoff da ist aus meiner sicht vor
gut einem jahr und ich sage absichtlich
gut ein jahr von heute an gerechnet bis
wir damit überhaupt nutzen könnten nicht
daran zu denken oder eben durch eine
immunität in dem die bevölkerung eben
die infektion durchgemacht hat wir
dürfen uns ja nicht drüber
hinwegtäuschen dem er mal an wir würden
die ganz deutschland jetzt drei oder
vier wochen lang still setzen so zu
sagen wir machen einfach den schalter
aus keiner bewegt sich keiner kann der
anderen anstecken dann wäre das virus
zunächst mal irgendwie weg weil die dies
hätten würden entweder überleben oder
einige würden auch sterben so wir haben
eine neue situation nach vier wochen das
wäre aber die gleiche situation tabula
rasa wie am anfang
das heißt wir hätten ja wieder kontakt
auch mit dem ausland hin und her
irgendwo hat das virus
selbstverständlich in einem menschen
überlebt nicht bei uns vielleicht
irgendwo anders und schon ging der ganze
spaß von vorne los also das würde uns
auch nichts nutzen wir brauchen eine
stetige infektions anzahl die aber nicht
zu groß sein darf
so wird das gefragt sie haben gesagt
also eine längere zeit ein jahr die
impfung oder diese herdenimmunität
können sie tatsächlich jetzt sagen also
wenn wir diese impfung in einem jahr
nicht haben haben wir dann bis dahin
zumindest diese herdenimmunität erreicht
oder ist das auch zu fuß oder hexe ja
kleines rechenexempel also wenn es
stimmt mit diesen 60 70 prozent die
infiziert sein müssten oder immun sein
müssen weil wir so eine gewisse
immunität haben wir haben 83 millionen
bundesbürger die derzeitigen
infektionszahlen liegen so ungefähr je
nach rechnung 125000 130 tausend rechner
mal mit 130000 jetzt gehen wir mal davon
aus dass wir eine hohe dunkelziffer
haben wir sagen mal zehnfach so viel
dann hätten wir 1,3 millionen menschen
in deutschland die jetzt schon diese
erkrankung haben oder gehabt haben 13
millionen das sind aber bei 83 millionen
grad ein bisschen mehr als ein prozent
das heißt wir hätten wir bräuchten noch
zu diesen 60 oder
70 millionen ganz ganz viele weitere
infektion bis diese herdenimmunität
erreicht wäre das heißt wenn die
infektionszahlen so weitergehen würde
würden wir jetzt nämlich schön niedrig
dann wäre das zwar für das krankenhaus
system gut weil das ist verkraftbar aber
die erden immunität würde sich auf sehr
lange zeit hinaus stehen so jetzt kommt
hier ein kommentar von makro den nehme
ich mal stellvertretend für einige
andere die ähnlich was gefordert haben
warum kehren die gesunden nicht einfach
zur normalität zurück und versorgen die
mit vorerkrankungen
dann hätten wir einen höheren grad der
immunität der in der bevölkerung und
auch die mit ernsthaften vorerkrankungen
könnten sukzessive ins normale leben
zurückkehren
was bringt das herumgeeiere das virus
wird und schließlich erhalten bleiben
und die wirtschaftlichen schäden sind so
immens dass es nach und nach an immer
mehr stellen hand wird also das ist der
vorschlag die menschen die bedroht sind
oder oder latent bedroht sind die müssen
sich weiter isolieren und der rest geht
zurück zur normalität
ja das ist ein vorschlag der immer
wieder kommt nennt er auch gar nicht von
der hand zu weisen ist da ist auch viel
richtig ist ein gutes dran
gerade im medizinischen bereich sagt man
natürlich leute die infiziert waren das
überlebt haben jetzt also zumindest eine
gewisse zeit nach zeit lang nach aller
voraussicht nach immun sind sollen
natürlich bevorzugt zum beispiel auf
einer intensivstation eingesetzt werden
dort wo eben das risiko besteht dass sie
infiziert sich infizieren könnten was
sie aber nicht mehr können weil sie ja
immun sind und so kann man das natürlich
auf den normalen sektor übertragen aber
aktuell stand heute etwa haben wir ihm
alle daumen 60.000 genesene 60.000
menschen fallen bei 83 millionen
natürlich gar nicht ins gewicht da sind
auch sehr viele gottseidank alte leute
dabei die nicht im erwerbsprozess stehen
das heißt wir hätten nur einen ganz ganz
kleinen bruchteil von diesen 60.000 die
jetzt eine arbeit nachgehen könnten den
aber sofort die nächste schraube um mal
irgendwann ein symbolisches bild
zunehmend fehlt weil ein anderer an
diesem arbeitsplatz eben nicht tätig ist
vom prinzip ist der gedanke völlig
richtig aber auch praktisch wiederum
schwer umzusetzen so schreibt er es
nochmal das hört sich so an als ob wir
alle krank werden sollen somit wird der
tod von vor erkrankten
menschen in kauf genommen ich glaube
dass es ein missverständnis sondern die
leute die quasi keine vorerkrankungen
haben sollen sich möglichst schnell
anstecken damit sie das virus eben nicht
weiter tragen können wenn ich das
richtig verstanden aber herr doktor
sprechen also soll anstecken würde ich
jetzt auch nicht sagen
es gibt ja ganz am anfang kam es auch
leute gesagt ja ich möchte lieber jetzt
haben als später dann habe ich hinter
mir
dieser gedanke ist nachvollziehbar ist
natürlich aber ein bisschen russisch
roulette denn wir wissen natürlich dass
auch immer wieder einzelne menschen auch
jüngere menschen auch ohne
vorerkrankungen einen heftigen verlauf
haben können das ist ja eben so man hat
ja auch überlegt dass man anders vorgeht
und sagt man lässt alles macht mal
wirklich sehr holzschnittartig alle
jungen raus sondern sich ruhig
infizieren und man schützt nur die
wohlhabenden also die die besonders
anfällig sind die älteren und die mit
vorerkrankungen das kann man natürlich
tun oder sollte man auch tun aber per
gesetz lässt sich das schlechtmachen das
wird immer ein appell sein dass man sagt
dass gerade die älteren eben noch
deutlich länger die maßnahmen aufrecht
erhalten müssen ja trotzdem hier lese
ich in den kommentaren so was wir von
michael auf youtube die kontakt
beschränkungen sind nicht einfach zu
ertragen oder schnupfen cookie möchte
einfach sagt einfach nur ich hätte
lieber corona jetzt als die ganze zeit
zu hause zu vergammeln ganz spannend
finde ich noch einen aspekt sie haben
also ich habe gab sie den vorschlag die
älteren oder die menschen die bedroht
sind sollen sich isolieren
die forscher der leopoldina haben dazu
folgendes gesagt in ihrem schriftstück
eine vorbeugende segregation also
abtrennung einzelner bevölkerungsgruppen
beispielsweise älterer menschen allein
zu deren eigenem schutz wäre als
paternalistische bevormundung abzulehnen
also da gibt es dann einfach gar keine
begründung keine wissenschaftliche
begründung man einfach quasi dass das
dogma jemanden einzusperren zu seinem
eigenen schutz
das ist paternalismus aber im grunde
sind wir doch gerade genau in so einer
situation dass wir alle eingesperrt
wurden mehr oder weniger oder kontakt
geschenkt um uns alles nicht ja es ist
nicht falsch also wir haben auch jetzt
quasi einen paternalistischen ansatz in
dem der big daddy kommt und uns allen
sagt was wir eben dürfen und was wir
nicht dürfen ja da kommt man natürlich
in schwierige diskussionen
nein jetzt betrifft es natürlich alle
menschen das wäre der unterschied im
anderen fall werden dass bestimmte
gruppen eben für bestimmte gruppen
gelten
es ist sicher auch aber da müssten dann
wahrscheinlich verfassungsrechtler daran
eine schwierige frage ob man das auf
dauer so durchziehen könnte oder auch
nur kurz vor sich her ziehen könnte aber
aus media als mediziner sage ich eben
natürlich wäre das sinnvoll für die
älteren und für die die vorerkrankungen
haben sich natürlich ganz besonders gut
zu schützen also das ist eben der
kontakt der großeltern mit den kindern
wenn wir eines tages mal scheiterte
antikörpertest haben also test sie
wirklich dass messen was sie messen soll
nämlich papier man schon cobit 19 hatte
oder nicht was wusste oder nicht dann
wären wir schon einen deutlichen schritt
weiter und da setze ich ganz ganz viel
drauf denn dann könnte man ja sagen
könnte man tatsächlich das machen bei
den kindern die enkelkinder die werden
alle durch getestet und wenn man
feststellt die hatten alle kurven 19 und
haben aktuell keine symptome und haben
auch die erkrankung früher schon gehabt
dann könnten die ja tatsächlich wieder
kontakt zu ihren großeltern haben und
solche tests brauchen wir das gilt nicht
nur für die übergreifende
generationsübergreifende kontakte
sondern natürlich auch im berufsfeld
diese antikörper test die wirklich das
zeigen dass testen was sie testen sollen
die brauchen wir also eine schwierige
diskussion die uns dann noch bevorsteht
wir sind alle sehr gespannt was die
bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder da morgen
beschließen wird aufgrund der
empfehlungen der wissenschaftler der
leopoldina aber auch wahrscheinlich auf
grundlage von anderen empfehlungen
herr doktor specht vielen dank für ihre
zeit heute abend für ihre antworten und
einschätzungen vielen dank für eure rege
beteiligung und die ganzen fragen und
kommentare
das war wirklich sehr spannend und wir
sehen uns dann diese woche auf jeden
fall noch mal wieder mit der nächsten
corona sprechstunde bis dahin sage ich
erst mal macht's gut
und tschüss
[Musik]
und wenn euch das team gefallen hat dann
guck doch mal da rein da haben wir mit
der finanz blockerinnen madame
moneypenny darüber gesprochen wie das
geld in der krise sicher ist oder hier
in den stream mit harald lesch über die
zukunft nach kroner und natürlich hier
unsere ganzen playlist guckt ihr euch
mal an und lasst ein abo unten leicht an